Donald Trump declared himself the law
Nordic candidate Trump claimed yesterday
that Hillary Clinton considers herself
above the law
a new poll this morning shows Clinton's
lead has shrunk to three points that
follows FBI criticism over her handling
of emails while Secretary of State major
Garrett is in Indiana where Trump
campaigns today with a possible vice
presidential pick major good morning
good morning Donald Trump did not
mention by name the two victims of Pula
fatal police shootings last week or the
roiling national debate over police
tactics and training he did say more
work needs to be done Trump wasn't
nearly so vague about backing police
after a week of tragedy and racial
strife America's Police and law
enforcement personnel are what separates
civilization from total chaos and the
destruction of our country as we know it
in his first public comments since the
ambush in Dallas Donald Trump praised
police tactics and criticized
anti-police sentiment it's time for our
hostility against our police and against
all members of law enforcement to end
and end immediately right now in case
anyone missed the message I am the law
and order candidate Trump echoed Richard
Nixon whose 1968 White House campaign
about law and order at a time of civil
rights and anti-war activism as far as
this problem of law and order is
concerned I am for law and order Roger
stone a former Nixon aide and close
confidant of trumps didn't shy away from
the comparison tweeting this edited
photo of Trump's face on Nixon's body
Trump is still planning to announce his
vice presidential pick on Friday and the
auditions continue New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie yesterday in Virginia
tonight Indiana Governor Mike Pence
pants as a former congressman with close
ties House Speaker Paul Ryan and a long
history of fiscal and social
conservatism Norah I will be watching
major thank you so much